I have no problem with political
division I have no problem with the two
parties being different I have no
problem with having a choice not an echo
when I go to The Ballot Box what I don't
like is people who hate their fellow
countrymen what I don't like is cancel
culture what I don't like is
organizations that are all operatives
trying to find somebody and Destroy his
life because he's speaking a point of
view that you don't like which exists
exclusively on the left and not at all
on the right I don't like that at all
and increasingly you're seeing this
you're seeing poll after pull shows it
that specifically the left in this
country hates their fellow countrymen
conservatives and moderates they are
more much more likely to unfriend them
on social media they are more likely to
cut them out of their lives they're less
likely to speak with them they're less
likely to know what they think that's a
big danger and so the way that
conservatives especially in our case
respond to that is with a little bit of
humor We Sip out of a leftist tears
tumbler because otherwise we would drown
you know there's so many all around us
those leftist tears